hi this is Jeff Lima for new media
rockstars I'm sitting here with Dan
Hennig the now legendary coffee shop
performer who rocked the world would get
low to the tune of over a million views
so I'm super excited to be sitting here
Dan how are you doing I'm doing great
thanks how are you I'm excellent not
about me there no worries so where did
you come up with the idea to do get low
in this style um in all honesty it
happened about a year ago at an open mic
I was with some friends and we just were
thinking of the most obscene songs to do
at the open mic and I came up with get
low and did it and it sounded atrocious
and you know then I kinda reworked it
and started doing it at my live shows
and then this video happened so okay so
it's it wasn't a completely spontaneous
thing it's something that you kind of
have generated a little over time and
fine tune yeah the song itself
absolutely yeah I mean now are you a
little John fan previously or was it
like pretty much an ironic
interpretation of it when I was 12 and
13 he was one of my biggest idols
absolutely but uh recently not so much a
little John in my life okay except for
this yeah I think I saw he actually he
retweeted your article and kind of was
cool with it uh yeah he did he called me
a pimp which is uh I mean I could die
happy I'm pretty sure so yeah that
sounds like a compliment now are you
familiar with like like a dynamite hack
or like say Jay Brandon or somebody a
couple of guys who've also done like
folk interpretations of those hip-hop
songs I've heard a couple of them like
Ben Folds you know that he did that one
I approached it and say the word but uh
he did I one of those songs and there's
a couple others I've heard like hey yeah
and all those and they just I've always
liked that
interpretation of stuff so I thought I'd
try it and yes it worked out yeah kind
of added your name to the the homage the
the came in of people doing good to
covers I like it now
none of your other videos have really
done the numbers that this one has done
so what are you like what do you think
was different about this or what do you
think how did well how did you catch the
zeitgeist honestly I think I owe all
this to my director who came up with the
idea of just going into a coffee shop
and surprising an audience and it's it I
think that's what it is the shock value
of it that really pushed it forward it's
I mean I mean either covers I think I'm
proud of them I think I you know I I
mean I like them I hope other people
like them too but this one really was
like it completely took the song in a
whole new direction from you know crunk
club song to an acoustic kind of
intimate thing with those lyrics it's
just something I don't think people
expect it and because of that it reacted
pretty well now now that you have the
public's attention let's say are you
gonna continue doing kind of those
covers or you get a bring in your your
own original stuff or what's gonna be um
my own original stuff has been on
YouTube it's uh it's on iTunes my
original stuff is my baby so I'm always
gonna be doing that but I do love doing
covers I'm going to be putting out a
cover next week if all goes according to
plan things change like that in this
industry so we'll see but um I am going
to be I love doing covers I mean it's
one of my favorite things so it's I
think it's a the the fondest form of
flattery they say is imitation so I love
working and kind of reworking someone
else's a masterpiece and kind of making
it into something different which is
also beautiful but you not be original
so I definitely am going to keep doing
covers I don't know exactly how dirty
they'll all be but I I yeah there might
be some there there might be something
along these lines coming again who knows
we'll see now did you get a pretty good
reaction from all the other people in
the coffee house there it's um good
applause but well I'm pretty sure one
older lady left in the middle of it
which is you know that's okay
but yeah I mean people it was kind of
weird just to set up
no one knew it was going to happen we
just setup in there and people just did
not expect it
I keep seeing people talking about like
the guy in the white in the background
laughing and the things like the other
guy who's not and I mean it's just it
was just
that's exactly how it was there were
people who just did not happen people
who thought it was hilarious so it was
it was a really weird by but it was
funny did the coffee shop know that you
were gonna do it or it wasn't even a
surprise to them well we asked the
coffee shop if it would be alright to
film to shoot something in there we
didn't really give them too many
specifics we did like yeah we didn't
give them they didn't know this was
going to happen basically but they are
very very kind and helped us a lot and
were completely okay with what we did in
the end even though they were a little
shocked I'm sure so nice what was the
name of the coffee shop just so we can
give them a shout-out b-24s in Ypsilanti
Michigan kind of repaint the favor yes
yeah they had the best anyone's out
there they have the best egg bacon bagel
I've ever had in my entire life now
you've got this you've got this
incredibly killer voices we've all
suddenly found out now have you ever
tried out for like American Idol or any
of those other things I haven't um I
consider myself a songwriter first and a
singer you know just behind that but I
you know I'm not writing anything off at
this point ever all these doors are
opening because of this videos response
so I'm not writing any any you know TV
shows off I think they're a very
valuable way to find talent but I
personally haven't trekked out for any
of them and I don't really know if I
will I might I guess we'll see now just
using like copyrighted music does it
does it affect your ability to say
monetize the videos you have posted or
absolutely I haven't tried monetizing
anything just because I honestly like
this
it was gonna sound kinda naive but I
don't really care for the money thing
I'm sure I'm gonna need to pay the bills
one day which wish you know right now
I'm doing with gigging but these videos
I never saw as a way of like paying for
anything I saw them as a way to get out
there and kind of you know share share
what I do with other people and I'm
really you know I'm really fond of
having it having it be something that
people can just go to and not have to
wait 35 seconds beforehand to see some
commercial before I think that's a
pretty cool thing that uh that I would
appreciate to see on YouTube so I mean
I'm kind of tried to stay away from that
you got that so whole heartbreaker
things gone cold I like that that's good
like all the right answers people are
gonna love it I dig this so my little
earbud back in I tend to drop that up
now what was it like for like say you
and your family when they you guys
discover that your internet famous like
what happens well I still don't believe
it 100% I'm still like in shock kind of
um it's funny ahead like the night
before I we uploaded the video I had
like 78 subscribers on YouTube and now I
have well over 9000 which is within a
week basically which is it's just crazy
it's unbelievable and I'm like so
blessed and thankful that this has such
a good response because it's given me a
way of a new audience from my music and
it's just it's absolutely incredible and
my parents and my brother and sister
both really I mean they can't believe it
either but they're really happy for me
too so it's just like uh my parents were
a little worried about the language of
course but other than that they're
they're really happy with it I'm really
happy with it all my friends we're
helping me out of really happy with it
so that's good now you've got to somehow
someway I see does this great photo of
you and the music producer singer
Pharrell like what was that about that
was at he has a I think he owns a store
in Chicago
and I happened to be with some friends
of mine who know some friends of his who
said come to the store in Chicago and
hang out and we did and got a picture
taken with him and I put that as my you
know I put that on my facebook again
it's like I mean doesn't mean anything
for Oh probably doesn't know who I am
but I thought it was pretty cool so okay
so it wasn't like the music executives
are suddenly swarming new kind of things
oh that's that's not why the why that
picture with Pharrell have enough okay I
was suddenly like wow is this guy really
gone nuts or what this is awesome
so well what comes next for ya um
there's a lot of things kind of up in
the air right now this video really
changed a lot of plans I had I was I'm
still planning on moving to New York in
January for school I'm a college student
so I'm a junior in college so I'm kind
of just I think I'm gonna still move to
New York still go to school and a kind
of gig and make videos and just do as
much as I can
we're talking to a whole bunch of new
people who want to about and kind of
make this into more of a you know a real
thing as opposed to just like a college
kid who plays guitar and sings wants to
give you as big a platform and as big as
obvious as you can so I understand that
you've got an original song you're gonna
be performing for us is that true yeah I
have a song called Chicago um that is on
my EP it's available on iTunes it's on
my website if you want to listen to it
live or listen to it stream yeah I wrote
this song right before I moved to
Chicago for school and I should I grab
my guitar and let's do it I'm excited
all right say this is Chicago
packets for a different line with a
skeleton key of the cold coaster good Oh
Chicago is where my sunken Harbor
sure if you ever feel like finding me
your face as the light beyond you said
the last goodbye I'm still not sure if
my spine will recover all my senses know
your day you left my life since then my
boat's been taking in water my heart was
like we're scared off the coaster Oh
Chicago is where my song cannot shoot me
if you ever feel finding me
I think you're gonna be a star man like
I love it you got the voice it's
beautiful all right well I appreciate
the hell out are you coming on and doing
this thing with us I know that you're a
busy man you got a crazy life going you
got crazy trajectories so I'm excited to
see what you do next
I'll be watching I know that and thank
you very much for taking the time to do
this Dan Henning shoot very much I
really really saved this all right well
cool well you have a good day and we'll
talk to you when we talk to you all
right then sounds good all right good
luck thank you